رمضان هذا العام ولا العام اللي قبله ولا
ولا اللي بعده هو الشهر الفضيل هو شهر
الخير والمحبه والعطاء والمساعده
بنعيشه بكل فتره كل كل سنه بنعيشه
بالطريقه اللي المفروض ربنا امرنا وطلب
منا ان نعيش هذا الشهر الفضيل بهذه
الطريقه لكن المفارقه الوحيده
المزعج كنا حكينا شوي قبل انا واستاذ
محمود انه اليوم بوضع لبنان
بفرق العائلات عن بعضها يعني انا ولادي
مضطرين يكونوا باشغالهم
اسوه بكثير شباب وصبايا الترو يغادروا
البلد الظروف الصعبه لانه هم بفتره بده
يامنوا حياتهم يامنوا مستقبلهم وطبعا احنا
ربينا اولادنا انه لا يكونوا متابعين لكل
هذه
المجموعات اللي دمرت لبنان ربيناهم على
محبه الانسان على محبه رب العالمين على
اطاعه رب العالمين ربيناهم على الخير
والمحبه والعطاء وليس على الاذى
والتكسير والحروب